the word amerita you know to the average
person nowadays drake has a song called
lumerita we see omerta on different
songs we see omerta being used in books
you know people are writing about it
it's got many different meanings but
what did america mean to you it meant
open your mouth when you in a dentist's
office
don't talk but the thing is a joke
when
it's a double-edged sword
if me and you have an agreement not to
betray one another not to talk about
anything to hurt one another in any way
shape or form
that's a two-way thing
it's not a one-way thing
we have disagreement handshake
we trust each other we do all kinds of
things together we're cool
but tomorrow you turn on me and do
something [ __ ] weird
what's a murder it's [ __ ]
you broke it
already
so what do you want me to do stay with
it
so i'll go to prison
for the rest of my life
to prove i'm what
tough
or how stupid the [ __ ] i am when you
broke it and you want me to go to prison
and you're going to stay home
or whatever he did he left the life
because whatever with the russians and
the whole thing
they maybe wanted to kill him at one
point
so he's going to be so tough and so
smart so good to alert he's gonna sit
there like a [ __ ] statue until we
blow his [ __ ] head off take his
[ __ ] money
his wife and kids could go see where the
[ __ ] they gotta go
well that's a brilliant move on his part
oh what a wonderful man is now he had
the balls to [ __ ] say hey [ __ ] you
and amerto and whoever whatever horse
you're riding on and leaf
that's a [ __ ] move that's not a
coward's move i was with a guy a black
guy fat cat nichols
the guy killed his parole officer
got a life sentence stood up
i was with him in prison tough tough
bastard good guy too his wife is being
mistreated
his mother was a drug dealer to stay
there robbing her for money somebody's
banging his wife
good support team right
everything's going good
then they get to have this papi nation
in them his old crew and tell him
there's a guy who cooperated and he's in
a building there's a squad car outside
there's two police officers one guy goes
and get coffee
when he goes and get coffee we could
shoot this guy's a young guy
and then we could go in and kill the
performer fat cat nick who says
absolutely not don't do it
no
they do it behind his back
the cop that they killed his brother is
an fbi agent the guy who they wanted to
kill in the house he has the shots he
jumps out the window he's gone
they miss him
fatten that fat cat nickel that's his
crew
they indict him again
this now on a capital case killing a
police officer
he's facing the death penalty and fat
cat turns around and says
[ __ ] this
and cooperates
guys will say he's a rat
is that a wrap
don't know about that
what do you think about america i'll
tell you what
america is and again
i learned it from my dad
when you take that oath this is what my
father's opinion was michael i don't
care who
betrayed me i don't care who ratted on
me i don't care who how bad the life was
i took an oath
and i couldn't live with myself if i
betrayed that old i don't care what
anybody else did that's it and i'll live
this way until i die
i'm going to die that way with my boots
on he didn't care who wronged him who
did this who broke him as captain i made
that oath and i'm not going to betray my
old that's what olamide is you took the
blood out you agreed to keep your mouth
shut you knew you weren't entering uh
fantasyland it was a criminal life we
knew what we were getting involved in
and we have to shut him out that's the
speech he gave me and the reason he gave
me that speech because after i had
walked away we didn't speak for 10 years
who was mad at me who's going to kill me
my dad went along with the contract i
heard everything from the government he
finally said for me when he realized i
wasn't hurting anybody because everybody
was saying i was putting everybody in
jail and i go see him we're in the
kitchen of our house
why did you do what you did
i said let me ask you a question dad i
said you're on your third parole
violation we're sitting in this house
i says
you have
a daughter that died of an overdose of
drugs
you have a son that's a junkie
a lot of trouble there you got my
mother's a basket case and my other
daughter's dying
that's your legacy
i said i don't expect you to take
revenge on anybody but after your third
parole violation why didn't you say i'm
done
pick up your family move the hell out of
town so you don't get violated again and
and worry about the family you don't
have to be a rat at that point what are
you betraying you're not tall enough
you're not doing anything no i'm a rat
if i do that
i don't understand that mentality
i didn't i didn't get it so for me what
it meant
it meant what my dad said no matter what
this is the ulti we took and we can't
violate deal
i violated my oath i talk about the life
i left the life so i betrayed my old and
you talked with agents i talked with
agents that's cooperation
michael yeah we can't wait listen
you're bringing this up now no no no no
they're not gonna accept that you don't
have to accept it but the reality of it
is his is my thinking nobody has to
agree me and everybody
whatever you're thinking is the reality
is that you
sat with agents
that's breaking or murder i said i broke
it i betrayed my own yeah and you talked
about your crimes and everything else
that's cooperating and that's a rat
just like everybody else
who cooperates
it doesn't have to mean that you took
the stand
sammy would you break that off i broke
it but i already agreed to that yeah i
betrayed my own your father had a
mentality and he's not the only one okay
but there's hundreds
let me finish
my thing was
i'll talk to the government
but i'm not going to put anybody in
prison
i'm not going to go to that extent
huh it's not your call it was my call
because not your call sam i could have
taken a stand three or four times listen
i could have taken this listen
john
no no john riggy i'll tell you why i
went back on parole why they violated me
they brought me in to testify against
john riggy my friend
brought me into newark while i was on
parole picked me up two agents brought
me in said we're putting you on the
stand because he and i were partners in
a business in new york
and i refused
i said back within 10 days i was
violated because he was my friend i
couldn't do it i don't know about that
i'm confused too okay but but by doing
this that doesn't mean i didn't
cooperate
no no let me let me let me make a point
then you can have the floor yeah i got
my point is
when i got out of life it wasn't because
i was mad at anybody did people do me
wrong yes they did but i understood
that's part of the life this this life
is a treacherous life no matter how you
look at it i've seen backstabbing i've
seen guys get killed for the wrong
reason i seen what happened with my
father
you want to know something when the
government came after me
they had real reason patrick i can't say
i was framed the giuliani case it was
questionable i beat the case okay i get
it you know they're on one side i'm on
the other
the gasoline case i was guilty
i was guilty
when i took the plea on a gasoline case
there was no cooperation involved i got
a 10-year prison sentence 15 million
restitution no cooperation didn't talk
to anybody nothing i did that because i
beat them five times i had leverage over
the government i made my deal because i
was already planning to walk around all
right no no no no no
no no let me finish no this is important
i was in custody
they're taking me down to florida where
i got indicted again on the whole
gasoline case
we agreed that the case was going to go
concurrent with my federal sense but you
got to plead first in the state because
the feds won't go concurrent with the
state but the state will go concur with
the government so i pleaded
to the state they gave me nine years
and on the way back i'm on the plane
with 10 agents who took me down here
and i'm teasing them they're asking me
all right michael now that it's over
when we when we were watching you here
was this what really happened they're
asking me all these things
and they said to me i said to them you
know why i took the plea i said i was
tired of beating you i beat you five
times i said let me give you one you got
one
you know one agent looked at me i'll
never forget i see his eyes right now
and he said to me michael
not this time
you became a superstar they were lining
up to testify against you you were going
down
i never forgot that
and you know what he was right
he was right i don't follow what all
that meant that's a good speech no
it's not it's it's explained
you said your speech
it wasn't a speech whatever it is it
wasn't a speech you were explaining
talking with the agents about your
crimes when the guy was playing against
you and you cooperated against some
jewish guy what jewish guy you told me
you said nobody wants the amount i don't
know who the [ __ ] you sammy you i got
subpoenaed to testify in that case and i
went in and asked the guy right he got
into one day's time not one day he
didn't do an hour in jail talking about
maybe this nobody walters whoever it was
well that'll get the facts if we have to
go to that round you could get the facts
i got a lot of agents i know it's public
i could get it [ __ ] the public record i
could get the unpublic record but what
happens is when you talk and you
cooperate with the government
now they don't use you
you're not going to take the stand
you talked about your crimes you talked
about other things and you got the plea
or whatever they do they gave you his
plea it's a problem no you're wrong
you're wrong i did not there was no
cooperation attached to my plea
agreement in 1985 you can investigate
high low and everywhere in between you
can look up documents you can go to the
freedom of information act or whatever
you want you can't i don't know
information well you got fbi connections
you got fbi connections you just
couldn't there was no
there was no cooperation ten minutes no
but there was you just made an
allegation that's not true there was no
foreign
there was no cooperation attached to my
plea agreement maybe it's not
cooperation i don't know what you wrote
you met with the agents and you talked
with the agent
five years later
i just said you want to play with agents
and you were joking i had [ __ ] once i
didn't go for that [ __ ] what are you
talking what are you talking about you
just said you were talking about agents
i beat you so now i'm going to give you
sami i took i was talking about my case
i took a plea
i was talking about my case they were
saying michael when we were following
you here was this what really happened
well
is that when you talked with the agents
you talked about your crimes you talked
about other things
now what happens is they didn't use you
they didn't use it you couldn't use me
uh sam
i've been listening to you and i don't
want to say it but i think you want to
say but you haven't said it yet is there
anything you want to say to michael in
regards to cooperating what can i say he
read it
he cooperated he cooperated with the
[ __ ] government he wants to get on
his [ __ ] high horse i didn't send
somebody to prison he met with the
[ __ ] government and read it you're a
[ __ ] rat i'm going to talk about
respect you want to talk like that point
your [ __ ] finger at me or what are
you gonna do what am i gonna do i'll
break your [ __ ] face what the [ __ ]
i'll do let me tell you right you're not
this was jesus
really yeah
you